I'm not big enough. Hold on. Give me a boonie.
Also me and my dad's wife.
You know that?
But what should you know that meme that goes I for real think I just got a virus?
Me with his background music right now.
Randomly has like the best background fucking version which is rather odd and unexpected.
Which I didn't.
Did not expect from Dungeonclawler.
Wait hold on.
Just making sure.
I like wrote my little notes on it and stuff like a little nerd.
I was like I want to talk about this game.
I'm on my high rate plan.
Good morning. Good evening.
Good afternoon.
I for real think I just got a virus.
Can you hear the loading like menu in the background?
Randomly has like the coolest bdm randomly.
Also why are you gifting me memberships offline?
Thank you for the 50 gifted momolo.
The 10 gifted mns188.
I always want to call you marks and spencers I'm going to be honest.
Envelopingly saying thank you for the 10 gifted membership Jesus.
Jesus I didn't do anything so I'm not sure what's going on.
But thank you and I hope congrats to those who caught up with your play.
So this game is called so instead of what's called a dungeon crawler it's called it's a claw type
machine game lgf get the fuck on out of here with that profile picture.
Thank you for the 10 gifted memberships and congrats to those who caught up with your face.
So instead of a dungeon crawler game it's a claw machine game called dungeon clawler.
Was that even loud enough?
I can't actually hear the sound effect.
I don't know if that played.
Did you hear bdm please be honest.
Be honest did you hear bdm?
I never heard it.
It's too loud.
Okay that makes sense.
Eight minutes.
188 thank you scary you almost got my name right.
I know.
Marcus!
Fuck you I'm just guessing.
You already know I'm here.
The moment I see you live thank you reverse.
A must stream element is broken oh god.
My stream element is broken what have you done reflans nothing's loading just say the
wee messages that normally.
Oh well okay so we're gonna we're not gonna join the beta fish where's my cursor there you go we're
not gonna join the beta fish so this lovely game is called dungeon crawler it is a demo okay
it's a demo so don't get too excited don't get don't start pitching tense not complete not
finished this is version 0.25 to be very precise dungeon crawler is a rogue like not like like
with a kicking car claw machine deck builder build your unique deck fight enemies by grabbing
weapons and items from the claw machine and find special artifacts that help you on your quest
to reclaim something you lost aim carefully to claw your way through this dungeon okay
so I watch video game reviews as I go to sleep to see if there's a game that might interest me
um build a unique deck oh shit is that my accent can I see your deck
is that my accent thank you let's write for the five gifted memberships and dot gore for the
tent well I'm gonna be honest that's the lock the new emotes slot what do you want in it
um
icicles embers and mercers is up first on the chopping block for the next batch of emotes
um I go last Zura and she be will be next sure take a look can we see your dick I mean
hey your wish is my command
is it true if you watch a vod on 0.5 or 0.25 speed you get more watch time income
um I wouldn't recommend it it might be plausible for you I'm not sure Ali vivas
vivas las vegas refigas love you momo love you reflin thank you for your super chat very kind
of you the booty lord for the extended membership it's been a month and I have loved every moment
of it love you momo love you remember that time I got the thunder waffle stomper and black ops one
right I have two more notes so I actually wanted to do this thing where we gave like new games or
indie games a bit of a spotlight before anyone's like why are you like absolutely just slurping
off the knob of the same relax um I'm not being sponsored I ain't been nothing like that um I've
always wanted to do a bit like either an indie game thingy a smaller dev team or something of that
nature um reverse thank you for the extended membership love you all get the dub strongy as
always we get the w's in this house um yes I if I was if I was a young little seed a little developer
seeds you know all it takes is one person to get shine a little light on your game and you know
it's kind of like um it's just kind of like be you know do what you want for others what you
would want done to you so I saw someone play this game as I was falling asleep and I was like
Ken what it's in the demo it's coming out this quarter four this year so it's already on its way
and the demo's pretty wrapped up people have racked up 10 hours in the reviews and I'm like
oh I don't know if we're actually gonna do a run or not but um long story short Stray Fawn Studios
is both the developer and publisher and they have 24 games under their radar roughly I think they
have a few bundle packs that Steam might have counted as its own game like put published on its
own but that's not quite right they've dipped their finger into many pies but it seems that they
prefer strategy games and you could definitely confidently say they actually specialize in
strategy games um I don't care what you play I'm just happy to be here I'm just happy to be here
yeah so I'm gonna see if monthly we can try and do an indie spotlight or small studio spotlight
um and I'll kind of talk a little bit about teeny tiny bit about the game of the dev team and
then we'll just get into it and see what our impressions are um I personally personally
actually really interested see how the game developers like do do because the gameplay
of it looks really fun and user friendly you know me if the game looks like I don't have to
think much to play it oh I'm all over it like a damn rash um fake gamer by the way uh so we'll
do a run we're gonna see how it goes I think the only feedback that I saw was that they might not
have sound effects that like give off the reward system when you when you you know to hit your
dopamine receptors when you pick up stuff but we'll see I don't know maybe they won't do that since
that but um yeah we'll go for it so it's like a cute kind of you know I'm gonna say controversial
the art style actually reminds me of Mugenics which is what
um Ed McMillan is doing the creator of Isaac right now binding on but the head video game
binding on Isaac yes um he is doing a game called Mugenics and it has this kind of art style um
it's not right on the thing but anyway so choose your character sir bunalot sir bunalot
used to be a knight but he gambled away all of his coins and he fell from grace there's a space
between coins and oh games unplayable sorry devs I need to give you that feedback right now games
unplayable he is now on a quest to reclaim his lucky paw which was chopped off by the evil dungeon
lord okay so we have a quest to get back what was once ours
so our deck if we pick up a sword attacks an ear's enemy for five damage blocks damage by five blocks
by ten double the amount of block when picked up alone does 10 damage or 20 if picked up alone
which is rather things well just default because I've never played it there's no point how to play
collect items using your qualified enemies however your mouse cursor over wait oh however no however
your mouse cuss shit wait hold on let me drink this let me take a slurp of a tea do you really
like strategy games um I like games that look easy like I think that's why I don't mind a good
routine make sure you because it's like just shoot your way out of the problem
just throw a few grenades here and there's like I will get over here it's fine
would you like recommendations for other indie games I absolutely would love recommendations
for indie games I as I said I would like to maybe monthly we take a look at an indie game
like we purposefully take a look at an indie game and we become game journalists and forget how to
double jump um for the day just for the for the the heck of it for the tea and right use
WASD to move on the map use the A and D to move the claw space to drop the claw space to close the claw
back space to skip your turn when would it be advantageous to skip a turn you can change the
game speed and settings got it right so it was a bit slow right w got it right okay so
so as we see okay I don't want to be too big for this hold on maybe I should be like
skinny tall you know I'm saying skinny tall right so this is our juicy claw that's controlled by
my WASD this is all our deck but we'll see our deck um 100 percent of the time um it's always
exposed to us the deck is always exposed yeah yes it is three points um so there's little
squidgy slimes and we attack the baddies down here we can see their health bars 27 27 we're 110
with the uh five block buffer I guess your health has increased by 10 start each turn with a block so
we know these swords do 10 so if we could get three swords in a go we'd be able to whack out this
little slime but yeah and the slime also gives your heads up that you're going to be walloped for
nine but uh that's it oh shoot and then there you go that that's that's the gameplay there's a oh wait
am I an idiot I did another 10 oh it's five the long sword is the other one right okay well we're
picked up a lot of me sword we picked up a lot of blocks so I think that's actually not that bad but
as I said one of the feedbacks was there's no like which which went fatang but I think that's just
because it's obviously a demo this isn't a finished although I would argue from the looks of it on
the surface it is rather finished um uh we just came the I don't want to accidentally hit the claw
over here you guys can see my cursor right right and but yeah it's like a turn base oh that was all
defense that's rubbish well he's not gonna hurt us that's good news and as the pray polish them
honestly they could easily have just been like no I don't want to right please get the sword or I'll
cry okay there we go is that enough to get on no but yeah that's it that's literally I just saw it
it looked simple um and I saw it was like new on the come up if you want to argue it's on the come
up and they're definitely gonna add a specific but yeah meet us as in from the video game binding
of Isaac converts all fluff inside a small rate no increase your block by three and gives you five
spikes so if something hits me it'll get hurt so every time we finish our rounds successfully
I just said floor one of five on this one um attacking the nearest enemy deals three damage
plus one damage for each 10 gold coins you have what the heck we're deck building like balutrol
I mean that's my best game uh I don't even have that much money right now though so I don't even
think we're gonna get much benefit from that that was actually really good though oh you can move it
whilst I'm there he's doing the attack stuff I did not realize that um go that meet us touch
literally from the video game binding of Isaac I think it's always better to just go for the juicier
sword because it literally does 10 which is equivically I'll maybe get these three oh no it
still wouldn't be enough actually to get it but yeah this is giving slay the spire vibes wait am I
gonna enjoy slay the spire because of this but yes as I said this game comes out in this this year
and we're in the q4 they said but um literally just build your own deck and let it go you can
re-roll with mooney but I guess because we picked a money one then best keep it max what is this
you have statistics oh my lord okay brass knuckle attacks the first enemy for two and gives you one
dodge interesting the mama are attacking the nearest enemy what by shoving it up his arse
dealing 0.5 damage for missing health you have deals three damage to yourself no wait these are
terrible re-roll that don't give me that get one block every time you use an item I mean this is
highlighted so it makes me think I'm supposed to get it I'm just gonna get it and it it was highlighted
okay there but yeah there's like more gambas section so as you like go through the map if you will
you can like roll stuff question mark I'm not really sure what this part is I didn't understand it
much when I was watching the reviews but uh yeah what's this you remove three poison at the end of
each turn or you heal five after each fight that's really small whereas poison I think vaccine
there is like poison elements I don't I can't remember what the other elements are
so we're grabbing the gauntlet and I run a little but sometimes the games mean and I'll do that I'll
like shove you off of something that should have been yours I didn't get one I got one golden sword
one of the resource but I do have 20 oh they're just poking up okay so enemies can increase their
defense and stuff like that why did you ping the knife halfway across the map don't be so rude
I just think it's neat I think the dev team's done a good job of this in my in my humble opinion
you know I think the dev team's done a good job uh I'll be very interested to see how they would
develop it further because because of the gameplay I have seen and like the gameplay we're doing now
you know we're being introduced to new enemies we're being introduced to new items into the deck
the only way that I can see expansion is just like updates in terms of new items and new stuff and
either nerfing or buffing stuff like for a demo you're already pretty polished like you're already
kind of sparkling uh dev team I think you did a good job but that's just my that's just my biased
opinion because it's a super easy game to play and then doing my humble opinion converts all
blocks into strength at a 4 to 1 ratio I'm not sure about that attacks the nearest enemy for 1 to 5
applies 5 poison to the last enemy in the lineup I'll take that I'll take that
oh you can go for health if you need it and just random coins right we'll go for the piggy bank
midas's touch any meters hashtag any meter that couldn't have gone worse that couldn't have gone
worse okay our first boss in his name is prick wood the the dev team is not brash you can't tell me
the dev team is brish for real for real um absolute tragedy
oh no wait he's oh no just because I have one anyway so he's still gonna have poison damage so
we now have like introduced tick damage if you will which is really good what is he gonna do this
enemy intends to buff itself or other well he's on his own some so I think he's gonna buff himself
deals one damage to the attacker when being attacked right so I'm actually gonna get hurt for once
it took me to the boss to get hurt so I think I don't know maybe they'll balance the game a bit
less in the players favor to make it I don't know if they wanted like a binding of Isaac
experience where you can like fucking lose um because that's all that game is just absolute misery
I am absolute misery I spewed on me I've lost health um there's not been any updates that I've seen
by the developer that's handling multiplayer for binding of Isaac I'm just patiently waiting um
I thought that was gonna get either of the sword or the shuriken but that didn't work
I spit back on him
yeah we'll go for the big sword bigger isn't always better but for some reason it is in this game
I can't believe this this game aged terribly and it's not even aged oh it's not even a baby but
yeah they have like 22 reviews I'm so tempted to like put a review just to like help them out the
devs because I think they say reviews really help out um because people want like opinions of those
who've played it before and you know you're the first time you consume a game is really important
because like you might see something that you don't like and it can sway your opinion before
you've even touched the game so I don't know if we should like write a review together at the end
as well just to make it super nice and then you can see it on steam it just says like scrawny calls
I got to play this game um on stream and together we were having a blast like mucking about a wish
listing it and review it makes or breaks wish listing it I didn't know about the wishlist thing
I do I do see creators being like please wishlist this but I never understood like why is it because
it gets like pushed advertised more like more sales if it's been in the wishlist like percentage
wise instead of just like watching as a dev a hundred a cabillion percent agree with this
trying to get solid feedback is invaluable and super hard to get yeah wishlist helps the algorithm
on steam holy shit we're breaking the steam algorithm with this one and we're hacking it we're
in boys the steam algorithm I never even thought about that but yeah like so because the name of the
game is dungeon crawler every time you search it up sadly google is like did you mean dungeon crawler
you dumb peasant and it's like no there's actually a game so I hope I hope that they don't run into
too many issues with it and like it took me a hot second to get the title right for the stream
um I think it took me like three attempts to spell the game correctly and I just gave up and
looked at someone's review and copied the title from the review because I was like I can't even
figure out I'm having a stroke um right junk jet deals one damage to a random enemy each time
an item is added to the machine after the first turn interesting you heal five increase critical
hit chance by five why do critical hit why not reward these crack for the floor will break when
walking and develop will prevent you from going backwards so fight fight fight fight and then it's
either potential machine use your coins to gamble no I need the much money use coins to
upgrade weapons okay that one's definitely what we're doing we're going down but again
introduce to new enemies uh a whiz club uh cloppers in my game we're likely leaving you think
they can heal and then little slime boy uh wants to block and but yeah we're definitely
needing to get our damage up because I think we're about to take a wall of thin slightly uh or I'm
starting to worry we're about to take a wall of thin um yeah maybe moment you can make a steam
curator page where you have a list of recommended games you've played I didn't know that my profile
is private though I don't think it would work which is a shame did I get walloped oh no I didn't
take it I don't know how I didn't take any oh they're all hitting for 15 and eight
okay let's do the poison one as well I wouldn't mind a cheeky bit of poison on the last guy so
it's not too hard to defeat okay that okay this we're about to take a uh oh dear yeah we're needing
damars would anyone like to offer us damars
I hate that I know what cloughing is wait I thought a cloffer was someone who's in a my
little pony and the popcorn that goes with it does that mean something else
have I been using that incorrectly and everyone's like oh my god you're such a
my little pony fan I'm like I don't even know what it means
no you understood that right okay right yeah
little pony sonas you can never look at me the same again after her pony sona streamer so cute
though no it's my little pony
isn't it right call machine in real life very so fun I want to try the full machines in Japan
Japan seem to have amazing like arcades and stuff um they know what the hook is I don't
know if you watch that series where it's like a day in the life in Japan and it's like and today
we're gonna watch what like a 22 year old casino worker does and I don't know if you saw that episode
it was fucking blaring oh my god it was like inside the parlor was just like
because it was so loud um
and it was like a constant noise I remember I watched aki dearest I don't know if you've
ever seen aki dearest um she's a youtube content creator for the girlies um and she did like a
video just talking about it in general and she ended up winning like the jackpot and she was like
she literally asked the people there like did you purposefully do that because they had to get
explicit permission to record first um and she was like and like she couldn't believe that she
hit the jackpot on it because she was like that set up but I'm pretty sure casinos like face track
you and stuff like they have insane face tracking and they'll identify if you are her new you're like
a new customer and like they can artificially up the win rate and stuff to get you hooked like it is
minor it is a minor um like don't gamble as much as I like to tease about balutro and like oh you're
gonna 99 percent of gambas quit before they win big they the manipulation is insane like I was
watching this documentary on a poker match that got uh rigged um and like it was showing you the
behind the scenes footage of what they can see and it's like just everything everything is monitored
everything is in the house's favor like call me a follow new vegas achievement because the house
always wins you know uh warhammer attack the nearest it sorry I was a massive right we need
damage gives a bomb buff exposes after three turns deals 30 damage to all enemies I think
we're gonna have to go with this um the house always wins literally actually speaking of follow
new vegas sheepsters is doing that stream this month this week my fucking hammer
they took my hammer don't gamble give the money to mummy and said no the failing stuff is fine
right as much as I want the hammer it's literally only beside block stuff and I'm here to do some
damage I'm here to make it hurt okay I'm here to bring the world of pain for you
but but shroom I could heal itself destroy him at once take him to the principles up wait what's
through you what's the purple that's not mine I took poison damn oh no I have heels fuck you
bitch I have vaccine get wrecked I get wrecked get frickin wrecked and strict so I'm not gonna
take damage for that oh I'm so smart I am so smart it's in my team my school's having an
overwatch tournament what the what kind of school are you in that does that that's so cool I remember
my school was like a planning like a paris trip or something like that but I had already like
stopped going um and they're like they never asked they were never like starting are you coming on
this trip it was because I was hardly over there type thing I was like of course I'm not going on
your fucking trip to Paris fuck off but you guys get overwatch tournaments that's literally so fun
what the heck what are we I can't even remember one interesting thing that happened in high school
I got 100% on a biology test and I was really proud of myself that's not fun thing though like
that's just me I was just really I just thought I would did really well I just really like biology
I think it's cool for real though I got 100% on my ball what you did like a little married
and everyone was so shocked they were like oh story how did you do it and I was like I paid
attention in class I didn't mean it and like uh um don't be a dumb ass we I just meant like I genuinely
like listen and I like I just like education like once um I pop my clogs um I'm actually gonna go
into college to study different areas um it doesn't really matter what the subject is too much I'm
just happy to be there um I wanted to do a skincare course because I wanted to learn how to do ASMR
because I heard you can like do pop-up ASMR shops and stuff and I was always like oh that would be fun
but I wouldn't do it under like big stronticals being like no like it would just be like a silent
thing lonely grizzly glidly glizzy isn't that a hot dog I'ma keep it real with you I'ma keep it a buck
50 yes I learned that terminology I am hip and cool I assure you thank you for the membership
please enjoy yeah um moats I need to make sure I lock in on that moat slot ticking bomb uh gain
three block at the no increase why is everything blocked what's wood
wood and debt what's going on I don't want any there fuck it we're doing I call upon my Irish
ancestors because we're picking this fucking bomb up that's not funny you can't say that
what is this increased block by five upgrade for 18 coins attacks the nearest enemy for 15 that's
good what about you I don't have enough money oh they're all 18 there's not like anything about it
rightly bro okay we've got one thing I remember someone saying that about the a harry pot oh it's
a feral cluster this enemy intends to attack you oh really oh my god wait isn't that the phase connect
manager oh no I don't want to kill him I thought phase connect we're all right am I going mental
is that the phase connect manager my is it I don't want to hurt him I thought he did good for his
talent am I going crazy I don't know maybe I've just not heard anything but I thought he did all
right for his talents I'm sorry phase connect there's nothing personal does anyone tend to add
items into the machine okay let's pick up the hammer please kindly right so 15 okay that was it though
it's so big um it's probably not even worth it to pick that up no no phase connect in the game
manager versus manager no I'm not a manager anymore you take five damage while it spikes
I've not healed either as is it actually I probably should have warned you before we watch this
there's a very high percentage we don't make this out alive I just want you to know okay I'm not
eh I've never played it before I was just going through it and before the only reason I caught
my cogs is because I ended up hurting myself I believe it I guess we'll go with poison damage
build up with the shurikens I feel like that's getting quite effective which I'm quite happy about
I maybe should have buffed the sword actually that's what I should have done see how this is too
big I should have buffed the we longer swords um
not me saying them joking then the first thing I read as an Irish man
hi Oregon I'm sorry what did you say as an Irish man I hear by Grant Stroni the
I word pass which entitles her to joke about Irish alcoholism and domestic terrorism with
a repercussion no you're not to give me permission for that song
I'm terrible eh okay I'm sorry face connect I did what I scuba had to do I can't remember
I was like I had to do what had to yaba daba do attract all metal items
that sounds OP
oh my god it's so cute it looks like an axolotl oh it's called spookle hole that's so cute
and then a thorn but yeah so they're starting to get big because they can do two attacks now
oh wait what oh I thought the magnet went on the claw
what I thought the magnet went on the claw no no come on
hmm I was like mimic your mudkits hi little baby oh I'm so excited before come on I got um
we're gonna play are you sit right I hate this hammer so much I've learned my lesson I'm not
picking up the hammer again um cheap two dollar ass magnet honestly
and so we're gonna get stroney all the past no no why is that glowing what did you do
dodges one attack what they're haunted do you like hunt stuff why are they moving
I mean I'll just go for it but I think there's a ghost in my game
that's so spooky spooky maybe it's a buff for the first time right
that was trying to help me literally it's going halfway across the map
and the enemy perished that's cool small sword for attack attacks an
enemy for five damage and applies three poison yeah I like I like tech damage I've always enjoyed
poison in video games who are you night commander of the order of defender lot this enemy's gonna
buff itself well if he's not gonna attack me we can go all out on attack hopefully and just
kind of get a few 300 oh no oh no man I've got a bomb here I mean in video game in video game
in video game I'm sure the youtube AI knows when someone's playing a video game surely copium
surely the stream isn't gonna be deleted copium
no I think the youtube AI is rather curious at the moment so if you do live asmr it reacts
differently we've got wall up at 13 coming in
and oh my gosh that actually did hurt me I don't know if I should go all out and poison
not as dying on the second boss sorry I'm so bad at taking the wheel
can I like grab a ton of these
please I would very much like to win we've gotten by 100 down
195 health remaining I was 66 health remaining but he is taking tech damage block
does not reset you're cheating right I said get another bomb no
mommy you're the bomb I think they changed something cross the words yeah so if you do an asmr
live stream you'll be judged more harsher than uploading a video fail of asmr
I don't know why the AI would be different when it comes to the same content but that's why I've found so far
um so I'm not sure like I'm obviously I've actually my warning is about to expire on the 19th of
September when there was a time in September
um
but yes uh it's going to x I'm 32 health I'm out bro there's no way I'm gonna make it
onigai shimasu um it's ogre there's no way I thought this game was being easy to me
I don't want to start a new run because I suck
all right just give me all this damage please no
oh my gosh sorry wait hold on a minute wait why is he just absorbing everything
where's my poison blade it's down here are my shuriken I think I can't there's no way I can hit
the shuriken oh see you you freaking bam going halfway across the map you think you've been funny do
yeah all right the the poison's the only thing that's literally taking him down right now
I'm just trying to stack on it I really am I'll just grab all these what does this buff say
block does not reset between turns so like I'm having to do other things
and the claw takes half the things off I mean at least they got the game realistic when you play
the vending machine games in real life the the claw be wide open I couldn't give less of a oh my god
the full poison damage saved us each attack applies one poison I love poison weaklings no you're my
strengthlings no no you're my strengthlings you're not my weaklings at all my poor babies
I don't know if I heal between floors would be nice um I want to do attack poison I think it'd be good
um anonymous thank you for the tip sorry but I gotta do some yard work oh American spotted
sorry apologies char I gotta go get me done some yard work we'll catch the rest of the
vault but I hope you have you have fun Strowny and Reefland's got away a little bit of you moment
thank thank you anonymous thank you I'm gonna do poison which I probably shouldn't be but
honestly mystery room you don't know what waits you here your coins to upgrade items yeah definitely
perco mat get new perks use your coins to dispose of items use your coins to gamble no no we're going
up we're going up oh no not again I'm so sorry sprung a yard work as American yeah it's not a yard
it's a it's a gear then it's a gear then in Scotland I don't know what it is in Australia
the grass outside I'll just do the grass do we even need a bomber but yes okay we did heal in
between floors so if I'm playing it a bit risky by the boss fight that's okay I get fully healed up
it's really rested hmm I some is a little too good worry talking about hey shit his bridges
what fur that was the south park reference you are weakling you're weak to mummy okay maybe
we do gardening work callers weaklings we feel exhausted after a lot of physical labour callers
weaklings we what does the word make mean me okay I forgot more than I just picked up
all those freaking spikes what is that the enemy intends to attack you reflex reflex wet
we're working bomba let's get some defense going I think make means quiet and shy flirt
with refling make him a meekling okay thank you what other words we read let we observe literature
together callers readlings oh um what other words gonna think of rate of this very moment in time
we enjoy playing video games callers geeklings there's a sniper down main callers peaklings
we like sucking mummy's toes callers freaklings
attack the first enemy for two damage then damage is multiplied by strength I don't know
what strength though is as few reasons your strength by two attack the first enemy
right let's just put a strength okay okay what's mystery room uh ooh
a part of the room is occupied by a small pond the air feels moist and warm what do
you do drink from the pond bottle some pond water sure you filled the pond water and receive
poison flask well I'm glad I didn't drink it jeez um okay let's upgrade some stew
we like eating mummy's food callers eatlings callers architectlings right what did I get
doubles the nearest enemy's poison because you're poison I wouldn't mind because this is small
yeah seven damage and six poison yeah I'm happy with that what about
were you 10 yeah you're worth it because you're worth it
we do a bit of pondering callers thinklings
we discuss our special interests callers kinklings
um it's becoming quite a nice deck yeah each attack applies one person
start each fight with three strengths I don't I don't know what strength does but I'm going
all out on it I said what I said right we'll do the fight because let's see what we're enolizing
whoa that would have been such a good I would have been able to see what the poison kind of
does there whoa poison's the way to go
and upgrade in the attacks or the way to go because
he's already down
stab a gator he must be British we haven't showered in a week cause thinklings no not
pheromone links holy moly we are shredding okay we definitely need to um do our thing
attacks the nearest enemy for 15 decreases the damage by five each time it's used reset after each
fight so in theory that would be useless if we accidentally get picked it up okay poison I just
want to I just want to go out on poison sorry I always find poison in games so satisfying like
I remember playing darkest dungeon and I wanted to just use poison all the time and then I got to
the poison spore like sewer's area and it was never working and I was like what's the point
it's literally the best thing in game I feel so personally attacked oh you can reroll oops
yes I can but I'm going to keep my money for upgrades because that literally has like thrown
his head and I buy it crazy am I seven poison
uh let's just grab the him yep I suppose the magnet definitely does actually pay off as much
as I want to be a little hater all right that's definitely paying off the beeflings
feed my reflexly puts weight on calmer beefling
you'd love the silent and sleigh the spire then she poisons everyone then blocks all their hits
in the meantime wait I get to play as her or a man trouble and I go against her oh that looks like
tell me the shape of this little poison I know it's rather small on your screen
tell me it doesn't uh oh you get to play as her okay we're on it
attack the nearest enemy dealing 0.5 damage for each missing health attack the nearest enemy for
five damage increases damage by five each time it's used wait what increases damage by five each
time it's used 10 15 20 25 attack the last enemy for three damage and shrink three items
to make them smaller to put in the
fit a refill and up my call on my plug link that sounds like drugs though plus
heat gun seems okay yeah to shrink three items to make them smaller to come inside the claw
heat gun or skip look at heat gun not you guys already have an experience with this game
right let's try and grab more money this time four to ten or actual one singular fun
let's not get too greedy let's go for two
two
who that's that's not nice mothaniel mothaniel think about your actions right so we're gonna
grab the heat gun on purpose he's gonna buff himself so we have some time mothaniel
right so okay I like super shrinks them so definitely can pick up more let's grab a big
healthy hearting of items we like gambling calls gambling no you're not to gamble reflects the next
attack our default back to the channel oh I didn't mean that no I meant to press
oh a waste of a turn I meant to press the like over a bit and that was a waste of a turn as well
you know what I'm actually throwing you know what enemy turn
what did you do what
if I go down am I only gonna get confetti
what even oh my god what
I I took how much poison damage
bruh this boss is hard Crackle hit chance five magnet strength fluff count
uh I don't even know what to do because I'm gonna pick up like literally four here and four here
you poisoned yourself literally I don't think there's anything I can do
other than just take the L oh wait oh it went against me because of his little silly
redar buff thing but in general it would go against him
huh
just gamer problems when you play game for the first time and I've completely effed that round
up okay so poison damage if I could get the the the plug link then if he's got 42 does
that make it 84 I'm gonna see if I can get it and we're gonna test if I can get 84 because
that would be pretty wild 84 oh Ken wet Ken wet
oh no oh go away go away is that why is that why I would want to skip the turn because he's got
that horrible thing on him what a rubbish turn what is he gonna do this enemy tends to modify items
in the machine I'm just getting shacked this is the it's not looking good
I don't want to so he's got that reflects the next attack or debuff back and he's gonna hit me for
20 and have 44 health oh
the shaggy suit what is gamba name is this it's called dungeon clawler and I think I've just
perished myself because I'm not really sure what I'm supposed to do yeah I'm taking damage for that
that is an insane debuff like actually batshit insane
I don't know what to do about it like other than maybe just go for hell yeah like that
what was the button to skip a turn
uh hold on I don't know the button to skip the turn was
shies can anyone remember backspace
oh my god I actually saved myself because I was smart enough if you only pick a single item it
turns no reduced price for all services whenever you take any damage one remaining item from your
deck is added to the machine
maybe
gotta go work have fun I'll catch up all day I have fun at work me plan
call him he has to go to work call him work link I have to go to work right so that's the boss there
fake fake fake fake mystery room I guess we could just do the whole place I just like hit more time
right okay I'm fully healed up I have no health getting items that's my only concern about doing
this full dungeon is that I have nothing to protect like to reheal before the boss fight
if I start going about shagging everything in this I'm already taking damage
also how did I end up with two claws I thought you had to unlock that that was a freaking
steal that round though holy moly
right we literally just need one more thing to attack I think we got it that was a really good
one it's a jobby someone who goes to work no a jobby means a shite in scores attack the nearest
enemy for five increase block by 10 when picked up double
just keep doing poison all in baby an ancient looking chest sits in the middle of the room
what do you do open it hit the chest walk away open it was a mimic chest
bro I trusted you a little mimic chest and how do you repay my efforts
don't shuffle you always have two turns before the enemy does something
uh I don't actually want to waste an attack in quotation mark on that first enemy because he's
about to pop his wee clogs but I guess that comes with this kind of gate turn based game
mechanic you gotta fight who comes up first you can he just be fighting anyone can he just be going
through it just say you hate me honestly just say you hate me it's easier it's easier okay that was a
weird shot oh just and no more I think we actually might lose which is unfortunate
we'll go to the blacksmith and upgrade what we can
uh body armor attack hammer rewarded yeah I want to do that okay one more fight and then
we can go upgrade were you oh my god you're like those pokemon in like generation seven that I never
kept up to date with I'm sorry the new pokemon I can't keep up with it back in my day there were
literal pixels on a screen because it was pixel art um I think we're gonna do pokemon ruby but
actually I was thinking instead of pokemon ruby we might do pokemon white or black just because
that was like a highly rated one um and I think people might like it more like because of the
art style and stuff but oh my god how just pick up what's
I'm just we being trolled right now because what's going on
like I'm actually about to lose just pick up what's there
it's not that hard how did you have eight I mean at least it's not attacking right I said
we're gonna learn poison on this or so okay poison poison poison uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh yeah
straight build up that poison make a regret being born yes I'm not losing it I'm not gonna
I'm gonna get normal ruby or a mega ruby oh maybe we should do a mega ruby I completely
forgot they did that taxineers enemy fuck it we'll do a lucky stick we might roll big
right I would like to buff
poison for 21
uh-huh and then upgrade my but for triple damage that's pretty crazy
strength and all that I don't have enough to do anything else I'm wondering if they had
for these crazy kinds of gamble gamble try to collect different awards from the small machine
I honestly don't even know if we're gonna make it to the boss fight
uh honestly dinny can add dinny can because I keep messing up poison maxing literally it's
my favorite type of attacking game like if we're talking on skyrim terms obviously it's
two handed then it goes bow and arrow but I would do poison if it wasn't so tedious which
sounds terrible oh my god I'm gonna game over no right we're doing another one wait oh no well
it's a demo so I wouldn't save but yeah that is the core mechanic of the game I definitely need
to pick a heal because that was a bit silly a bit silly willy a bit silly belly a Skyrim stealth
archer I've always wanted to try it to be a stealth archer in Skyrim but I just can't stick it out I
get so annoyed when the enemy's like two centimeters from my face and I literally have a bow and arrow
like sticking out um like right in their face like how's it what you're doing please do not
the strong tingle seller I'm going to bed I need your strongest tingles I have good news for you I
have another rambling ASMR on the way so for 5k it was supposed to be me tapping on stuff but
you know me I was getting distracted so it's like 25 minutes of like rambling ASMR
and then I've just got a no talking one coming out after that back to back um I did
uh two collab scripts and I sent them away uh one collab partner already responded the other
needs time to cook um yeah I've got a bit of work done um scrappy sir buns a lot strange
cousin who's obsessed with metal probably cuz he grew up in a scrapyard oh reward for completing a
run oh they already have the the first claw next turn will be a big magnet that attracts all metal
sounds pretty cool oh my gosh is she be Felina Felina was always made fun of because of her love
of carnivores she swore that she would one day tame a tiger but so far she's only managed to tame a
house cat that's so she be she literally has her wee a kiddies the booty lord thank you for the
super chat you never intend to come to stealth art it just happened I tried to do it and then I
always end up two-handed heavy armor like without fail or actually two two-handed light armor because
of the thief's guilt armor literally I love your latest patreon audience for me oh I thought they
were a bit um how many characters have they got you regenerate one health when you deal damage
oh that might actually be better for me though cream puff fights at your side for three turns
oh I think I'm gonna dolly no one really knows where dolly came from one day they just showed up
in the dungeon most assumed that dolly is a discarded pin it's embers literally look you've
got your little heart at the front as well for the bleeding heart hey not the bleeding heart the
pin pals is that the fight of 87 or deal 20 damage to yourself in one term to unlock it
she increases strength by three bad stress falls bent whoa what they have so many
characters right well please forces your pet as much as I want to play as she be I feel like
I'm only gonna win on the vampire fang I'm sorry she be forgive me forgive me there's a lay
mmm it's a make she be they're kissing right now the billy audio was great gonna listen to
the click this one I thought I hope you enjoyed it um as I said we're gonna write the next one
together because I always find them more rewarding right so our deck is very small right now so
we're really just gonna blast through it but yeah we're getting a little little green number ones
hey yeah I think I think this game's got a lot of potential it'd be very interesting to see how
it transpires how it evolves as I said the only thing I can imagine that the dev team really
need to do is just update more items maybe more characters I don't know if they want to deal see
it um fills the machine with water no removes all stacks of poison now attacks the last enemy for
five and heals your health wait why didn't I not unlock that in the other one that seems so much
better literally right we're health maxing this game I'm not even kidding we're health maxing
can't wait to see the scrawny characters are going on could you imagine if the devs are sitting
watching this right now and they're like yeah yeah you know what we're gonna we're gonna put a
slag in it fuck it we'll put a slag in it hi dev team how's it going easy it's not small it's at least
average I'm sorry your decks only got three to it that's right I'm deck shaming different
characters get different items yeah speaking of different
I tried to turn but I got too shy and it never came out
right we're health maxing sudden tentacle call girl oh could you imagine little slimy girl I get to
play I want to be all slimy and tentacle yonk yonk yonk and then drop it down
and then we did it and we didn't take any buzzes free that's an improvement credit card
attract the first enemy for one dart what oh attacks the first enemy for one damage
spend five points and permanently increase is that mixed by two
what like two to four to eight no that's broken I feel like it would be highlighted if it was
super rare attack the nearest enemy for 10
slamlings rise up considering the size of the reefland three is a big comparison body size
honestly I was reading my my special interest and it was the one I remember and it was so cute
and I love it here's five coins time to power up thank you momo honestly turns water into poison
water but I'm not poison immune there must be a poison immune attack the nearest enemy for 20 but
lose five health fucking hell right we'll do that only because we make health back right get
thank you momo for the super chat we're powering up small thanks I want the sword to be small
because if it doesn't fit in the claw swamp there's always 20% water I don't know why you don't like
can if you kill a poisoned enemy apply apply it's poison stacks to the other enemies oh my god this
is a game for me I'm sorry I love loved me poison love me damage simple us we do need just need to
get poison weapons though because we don't have any poison at all right now um we're trying enemy
turn oh we have no defense actually took me how many rounds to figure out we have no defense I'm
going to see if I can get that healing wand um have a good nap yeah the game too cozy you can't
stay up you want to fall asleep you want to get cozy embedded I'm having a snooze after the stream
then I'm getting back on the ground gamers oh yeah um a true gentleman actually I'm gonna add that to
my sand board um a a snowberry right clipped AC and um for it just it tickled all the right
wrinkly parts of my brain and it's just AC going a true gentleman and then a gong gets hit actually
I might be able to have it because I've been putting in the discord like I don't really like it hold on
hold on I've got it I've got it you ready I'm gonna add this to my sand board I'm gonna add
everyone to my sand board at one point oh no you can't hear over the game right fine you're
getting a link to it instead because I'm gonna add this to my sand board I'm gonna add like
something from the girl true gentleman it gets stuck in my head like I'll wake up in my brains
wow a vitamin pill converts all strength in a block no why am I getting such a rubbish
attacks the enemy with poison yes that's what we want we want a poison max because we have
contagious venom oh is this even gonna work or am I gonna get like
two gentlemen gong okay that was good money that's the first time we've actually got that
right let's do poison and every time I do an attack I get a bit of health back
see I got four for that round and then we can grab the magic wand which does five damage as well as
heal for four on top of what the wand will offer yeah
almost fell asleep a few times on the way home oh please be safe I don't want you get mugged
it's become one of our favorite in jokes is it oh that's adorable I love oh no wait
should I not do it then if it's an insider joke I don't want to ruin it for the snowberries
I don't have to put on the stem board I can pick something else from icicle
I keep hearing a stem board oh my god actually it is a stem board
when the reasons call me out on the tism what other ones have I got
hi Jason check is it too quiet it might be too quiet
unless you hear it through the the desktop audio as well
minimalist get through too strength no pinkish I'm gonna retake damage
no deals one damage to our random enemies payment added
can I keep some money
gain one turn that sounds good right
user coins to gamble no upgrade your items going down
I've watched your ASMR now I'm autistically info dumping about hypno to my girlfriend
your special interest isn't contagious I just think hypnosis is really neat I just
like when I was doing research a lot of the same subjects kept coming up and it was kind of like
safety was a massive one like some people were just going absolutely green eggs and ham on it
throughout history is my is Brian working have I heard Brian all day at all today
I just fixed it I just fixed Brian hold on let me replay that I just fixed Brian
I was like I've not heard Brian all day throughout history a lot of female killers preferred weapon
was poison care to explain yourself mama I don't know maybe because we're not as strong so it's
easier to just kind of be like oh fancy a shag and then stab them poison
I see if that's how it works right okay we can get shield I think we're gonna have to do shield
so it was seduction the art of seduction
um okay Brian's back I'm sorry Brian got scared thank you the beauty lord for the
thingy stab with poison spiders do it too the widow spider
oh my gosh we should get a puppet girl and then her motto will be stuff me
sorry that just came in my head like right now I was like oh that's genius
that's the amazing I'm gonna say that out loud
yeah that'll be her I'll make you a deal if I make a puppet girl that'll be her her code
sentence on the website is why don't you stuff me wink wink or something like that wink wink
and we're like um a puppet girl I love creepy little girls I've already said this before I just
find the design like 10 out of 10 um attacks and heals yeah I'm I'm good to double down on healing
this run and give it a good shot right poison get it up heals maybe should have invested a little
bit into that but hey ho
like a floggle a groke at cuckoo
I love when I upgrade the poison and there's like one
that would actually be great a sea slug gen mate sea slugs can be so creepy
uh I'm open to anything for the most part as much as I joke about like no Zee Broker
why is it so big did that click that frog did that on purpose
you green fuck no not the freaking the pinch on the one sword are you serious
so would we be puppet masters I think they are okay slime girl
which don't say those words around me again
if there's a chicken nugget can our website thing be did somebody say can see that's awful
that is awful I'm actually gonna have to think of it all this stuff again
so no slime puppet girl no no slime I've said dark sword deals 25 damage to news
anime lose to health for each item that gets picked up in the same town
is it bad that cuz we're a vampire I'm making it bad I feel like 25 is so OP like it's worth it
um watch me get like a I was joking all right there you go literally the perfect role
wait why did I get hurt you're such a wee thiber we already have a girl that's a slacker
named a strong what I have dare you are you squiddling me are you dare you level five would
L happy one month strong he's still gunning for the mouse train girl conductor to be honest
that is definitely a choo choo who wants to run a train on me type type uh
oh I've poisoned myself straight uh
I still think we're okay but no did I just get stuck up there I guess maybe when we drift oh
oh we did it block attack the nearest enemy for 15 and remove its block that sounds good to me
so is what it does um thank you again for the extended membership the mouse girl was a very
interesting it's just because she's a bit uniform and I don't want sheepster's toes being stepped on
especially if you're taking like a core design element like if you boil everyone's like designs
down into something
you gotta boil you gotta boil my daughters to to see what honestly I kind of missed that magnet
I'm not gonna lie that magnet was kind of kicking uh right so he's got like an infinite block so if I
use the war hammer on him is he gonna still have a block he is but it appears I can boil the
daughters to get to the broth I'm so excited to make my next move already I'm gonna give my
leftover soup to the birds and Gimli and Vigo have been loving loving watching me feed the birds
um I just put leftovers outside like I don't put leftovers in the bin because in Australia they
don't have so like compost bin like in Scotland the council like takes it away it's like this
wee fucking shitty plastic half not plastic bag and it's fucking shitting fucking shitty pissy
fucking thing and you put your food scraps in it so it doesn't go in the main bin um
but I put all any and all food outside so either the bugs get it or the birds get it and it's the
circle of life and uh Gimli and Vigo lose their shit when I start putting food outside because
they're so adorable they know what's coming and like all these different types of birds come down
and it's so nice to see like the diversity of bird types as well because like I feel like in the UK
it's like either seagull or pigeon pick your poison if you're lucky you might see a robin I
actually got to see a few robins which I was really happy about they're so beautiful um with
like the red crest on them um I just find it stunning do you have magpies I do they're very
friendly um I've named them strony and strony's dad basically that was shite try again um
because there's a dad magpie and a daughter the mum doesn't seem to like me that much
um she seems a bit more hesitant whereas the dad magpie's like so close to eating out of my hand
like so so close I'm not even kidding um I like birds I just think they're neat
but today I'm gonna get a big boy nap and then I think I might be reading a book to
no no weaklings again I don't know maybe we should lower that seems really OP if you think about it
increase maximum health by two no no by pets you can have pets no I think we'll do weakling
unironically um mystery room blacksmith perco mat and then Ben pushing cook now we'll go up
um a big boy nap mail on stream it's me I'm the mail all along you thought I was gonna get a
butter appendage I already got it
how about a harpy girl I'd be down for that um if you're asking if one's being developed then
no one hasn't been developed and I love pappy from monster misumi I don't care what anyone says
peak design harpies with the wings and everything peak design gorgeous design
one of the best designs um oh so he's slimy oh it just got slimy
all these weapons are getting rather big
hmm
hmm they're getting a bit okay what about the egg laying aspect of harpies
so I'm happy to discuss it if you are I sent off some notes um and for the for the birthing bros
I had you in mind
and uh but the lord did not it it didn't work out and I didn't get what I wanted
doesn't mean it might not be developed in the future but uh that one of the traits was you
need to help her pass an egg and I was thinking about you birthing isn't birthing an egg I don't
know I don't know what it's what it's called if it's like a wee thing
honestly I think we're fucking tearing them up mystery room you see a small spring in the middle
of the room the water meets the faint goal what do you do take a bath you shoot and regain 10
health that's not bad do harpies have a cochella isn't that a music please
uh right 25 damage if I pick that up 35 damage oh 35 though
see that would turn that up to seven and 20 health regain potentially
we are not struggling with health oh we can do two
hmm I'm going to do the weans because they show up more in the
they show up more in the wee thing reminds me of the episode
of interesting years cloca cloca I think it's called obvi no obvi poses what I do when I've
got an attachment my my income's out like bubba are they called like tapioca balls or something
like that like tapioca ball and critical hit chance remove three poison yeah I think we'll
move through poison we're kind of need to never have got our health and poison thing under we can
just max out on the damage platypus vtuber just kills you with poison loving bloom
bless her she she doesn't mean that holy moley that is incident as if you did a cheeky 20 on
me get to fuck man yeah I'll show you a chance I'll show you a 20 cheeky damage get right I ask
a fault that's a fault applies five damage yeah we're going to start doing the poison arc because
we're needing it oh please please be nice to me oh my gosh that was so worth it okay you you fucking
moth bastard right I've got heels I've got shields I've got everything that I could possibly need
just say you hate me just say you hate me it's fine not how I lost my poison as well right
how do I deal with the poison thing does enemy tends to modify iron reflects the next attack or
debuff so what I should only do like a wee bit like
like does that work if I only do shield
or should I only do like one basic ass sword and then I only reflect a wee bit on me
eight times
did I die on him last time no I made it by the skin of my teeth
what a fucking job he honestly I'm dead holy
holy shit I'd need the magic staff to recover what I can
I do get vampire bite health but he does 20 in a go
oh right we need magic staff for heels like straight I don't know maybe the vampirism
can bring it back yeah I think the vampirism can bring it back and we'll grab this heel as well
okay the vampirism definitely can keep us up
oh my gosh okay vampirism OP
heal eight health if you kill an enemy with a critical hit
the first item each turn is used twice
heals one damage to a random enemy maybe critical
it's just because of his bullshit mechanic I don't think any other mechanic gives us problems like
that great success every every time you see a job he I think of the of that
wait is it a job he makes you think of a
is that he's not possible is not possible
is the enemy turn oh I got a new short I got a short batch a AC has a new short batch on the way
so the sheepsters um uh AC's been cooking so snowberries and her harem
harem um have been uh turns water into lava why would that be advantageous
attacks sure 10 health is not to be snuffed up you see a small spring you should take the bath
restore okay I'm making stuff don't again jump in the AC with a hand job oh that makes sense when
you rate it like that job be job right okay that makes sense hydration check
um but yes I've got new shorts on the way in that
uh icicle has some sheepsters has some
uh but yeah thank you for clipping the girls as I said it helps hunt down like stuff that
should be turned into shorts like Amy's been going freaking green eggs and ham on shorts
she's been churning out insane ones as well like the scripted shorts she's been doing are
absolutely like fucking golden they're so good and like they all have the potential to like
seriously get trending like that voice one no um the one where she did her voice
um I thought it was really good like uh I think it has insane potential and the thing is even if
you upload a short and it doesn't get like trending right away um it can still um like get picked up
in the algorithm later that is the nice thing about YouTube that isn't quite possible elsewhere
you can always get picked up in the algorithm like my thigh cupping video that did really well
um it wasn't picked up in the algorithm until like day five statistically after 40 hours
if you've not been picked up then it's like done so but it is possible although rare I will say
it's incredibly rare like I've not really had it done to me much at all YouTube still has that
ability to kind of do that and so it is a bit interesting her real voice thing
ac clip with the penguin was cute weird game though
um her I was really surprised what ac's car nail exam
short doing so well but I think it was just maybe it was just like
it's adorable like hearing someone else's accent and then getting it tee he wrong a little bit
like I think people just found it adorable um but I'm so glad because ac was like really happy with
and her freaking tango ASMR stream so is to see it so blatantly oh my god oh my god um yeah you guys
have been absolutely cooking right poison seven damage yeah we'll do that shurikens yeah
um magic wand
uh I guess we can actually explore because we have the ability to heal
we don't have to panic she's gonna get a lot exposure with the high
side game or something oh did it come out did it finally come out
there was the opportunity for one girl's thighs to go up and it was sheepster's thighs
that was decided the most recognizable um so sheepster's gold it
and I'm so glad very cute yeah she nanced it today oh that's cute I'm glad
um it was a very surprising opportunity I didn't expect I was like what do you mean
uh bomba uh and uh just like you know you got this opportunity I'm like fuck okay right uh put her
in um because basically it had to be who has the most recognizable thigh design and it was shebe
and obviously this took a lot away on the makin so she wasn't tan at this point
um or however you want to say it so I I'm really glad for her sorry if I sound a bit tired I haven't
had the best um but I'm gonna get a nap and then I might read I might be selfish and read a book
and uh make something smart uh energy drink no that's gonna make my heart explode I'll do it
do we roll doubles your block in general no spaky shield and gives you five spikes
and gives you five spikes
give me five
let's do that why not were you
oh no we we don't do we don't do that here we don't do that here
mm-hmm uh let's try and grab these two
you don't have blocks skip those oh do not
right we're not gambling get over that
geez they really give you a hard fight right before the boss fight I'm glad we have magic wand
like leveled up so much I definitely think that's gonna save her booty cheeks quite well
uh oh blocking doesn't work on this character at all
you think I would have noticed I'm like hmm
shan't be investing in that shit anymore
the more attacked I get and the more health back so
uh
you know I'm actually wanting smaller
oh I hit the side right when I said I wanted smaller weaponry I didn't mean like that 22
relax relax right give me the freaking heels
I hit the side again
hopefully that's enough
oh I really wanted a bit more health before going yeah um I hope this boss thing right I
don't have blocks stop giving me it I already have a aren't anything
I'll take the freaking mirror holy crap give me the mirror for once please
okay it can be your pillow moment cuddle fish or
cuddle fish or cuddle cuddle cuddle fish you give me a tongue twister first thing in the morning
bend over it was in the character description you think I would have noticed that you think I
would have noticed that start each fight with block while I cannae and no I don't want I don't
want water in the damn machine anyway so oh it's a moth again wait am I going mental
right let's grab these and heal up fully and do a bit of cheeky damage
and then we'll grab the mirror no we won't talk to you I I was just being cheeky I was just
being cheeky oh oh do you want to do reflect attack you know what I want to do reflect right back
more like I'm not even gonna get a lick of damage on him at this rate no what
what
right right I'll take the ale I'll take the ale and grab all this
shite basically so then his stupid eight mirror attack in piso how much damage do these do
fucking how much damage
I thought they weren't even gonna do that much
I would very much like this golden heel but I don't want to hit the side
oh please give me something good with that holy moly okay we're at 37 41 if I can get this heel
and the mirror I'll appreciate it oh my gosh that was like I can't even seem to figure out how to
like counter whatever that pitch was increase the amount of fluff in the machine no increase critical
hit chance retain well camp blocks it has to be what oh wait if we win this do we win this
we may win this right what are you reward reward upgrade do we purposefully go past the blacksmith
to get more money for upgrade who said we can't do that
okay I'll take it I'll take it I'll take it I'll take it
I think if we do this we may win win
do you see the upcoming balutro cloud what's happening
are they are all the playable characters some kind of rabbit uh it did look like that from the menu
I think you maybe look we ain't winning if I keep getting pills like this I don't know what
can I catch up on I'm on right now this is shit I'm gonna take a wall of pin okay we need to go
back to the blacksmith and upgrade our shit like right now I'm not laughing I'm not he horn
I would very much like that heel
and very much like that heel
heel for six
can't use it sure
I don't know if I'm gonna regret going like so early
what do you do
increases its damage by 10 so it actually doesn't increase its base damage gives you the bomb
buff explodes after two turns for theory okay I'm gonna go one more thing I can upgrade
types of nearest enemy for three increases your base strength to four
that's big that's too big I guess base damage bucket I don't know that's the thing about playing
a game for the first time you can mess it up props on rain we've got bomb bar so we've got like
long term came to like damage coming up and I'm sure there's a much more whoa that was a
really good grab I thought that was all gonna come tumbling down to be on it wait how am I half
health already I would very much like those heels can I keep them both please you fried fish
honestly I don't know why you thought that was good please heal
68 doubles your strength attack the nearest enemy no doubles your strength right let's do a little
detour I might just pick up the healing ones honestly they're like carrying me I know I
know I have vampirism but I'm strueckle in I'm strueckle in
balutro and witcher balutro vampire balutro Dave the diver balutro among us
huh
wish I could stay longer no don't worry thank you so much for lurking in the shadows please don't
worry short us doing day and all that deep fried reefing
balutro went wild with a collapse I mean is a good game I saw there is another game it's called
like I can't remember it's about poker though it's kind of pixel like I think it was just bad timing
or something because you know but I might take a look into it's like really mischievous though
and different
I guess we roll because we don't have a use for money
fuck it
oh well we have money now I'll see if I can grab some cheeky health in that
reefing falls into the deep friarism that's horrible I would hate making that
I don't make normally like the funny hee hee right we're gonna clear a path to the boss by
taking out these two and then we're gonna go back and get fully healed up at that reward thing
that's you strength potion all right let's just grab some stuff
um mummy turning us into salt and pepper no I would never eat you except in the war
I forgot to reply to that artist oh my god I feel so bad I'll try and reply after I've rested
we didn't salt shrivelers I think so I think you're like slugs if you put salt on it like
hurts that's not nice
we're just gonna be poisoned attacks the nearest enemy deal and 100% of your block is
damn it I don't have these I don't hear block the damage
I'll do the dagger the reason
is because the smaller the weapon like the more chance I can get more of it and get my vampire
health uh-huh but as I said we'll get this reward that's behind these little slimes
yum yum yum yum yum yum enemy turn that purse slimes trying his best it's gonna annihilate
why did that go sideways I just had an image of us hanging out in the spot only for it to
the mountain we're in the large part in the sun no that's so mean it's like there's that artist
on Twitter that does that where it looks like a whole bunch of things that I feel like in the
details it's like absolutely atrocious oh I'm actually gonna skip yeah I know
bomba like bomba right rewards and then we're going to do the boss and then that's it
we'll see if we can do it uh I'm not sure how streaming friendly that's
ready melemon this enemy intends to add out into the machine and he's gonna do a block
curious can I start early on the bombs and reflect right I've got a bomb brewing in the
background and then should I do the strength portion maybe should do the strength portion if
I can get it though he's got 375 what are these melee bomb exposing deals 10 damage if it's not
removed from the machine deals 20 damage to the nearest enemy
what I don't understand that but when we grab this bomb here as well there's two of them
it's explosion city out here geez let's just like a free bomb stick in
he hits for 15 I need that like motherfucking healing right now he hits for 15 don't you think
that's a wee bit dramatic mate honestly I'm gonna see if I can grab this other heal that
was incredibly lucky I think we might have done it we'll whittle them down a half right he's put
bombs in I'm gonna heal I'm poison if it stayed but it didn't unfortunately no way we did it our
first one well it was in our first try but you know what I mean you know what I mean the first
try on the vampire we did it oh we did it against congrats you have beaten the demo against all odds
you have clawed your way to victory but it's only a temporary one for the evil dungeon lord is still
out and waiting for you you have reached the end of this demo you can keep playing but there will
be no new content at this point however the game will keep keep scaling and getting harder
snap crackle pot fried no I'm not frying them stop it booty lord spank I'm not hurting my
reflexes thank you for playing the game we'd love to hear your feedback for the demo and discord
and please consider leaving us a wishlist on theme okay well we leave a nice review we can write a
review okay right let's write a review together well I put it on screen I can put it on screen hold on
a gentleman here we go give me one momento uno momento por favor spingy spingy
um okay
uh hold on right oh that's just everything now and then we do this one and then we do this one
and then we do this one that was a little bit I got to take about the game and then review handsome
you're frying reeflings in there hey handsome you're frying reeflings in there but no don't
stop it you're gonna make me fall for it thank you chair for the service stop it I'm not frying
review right what did we like about the game we're doing it together mommy my English teacher
has a Scottish accent can't escape it what did we like about the game we're gonna we're gonna be nice
and review it okay I thoroughly enjoyed the claw machine gacha aspect to this game I would never
have expected that a rogue like would be able to incorporate such a unique mechanic
um the even by a demo standard
seeing the weapons unlocks and characters it is very clear the development team put a lot of
love a lot of love and thought into this game I cannot wait for its release and to see what
else is inside yeah plop plop plop plop plop the dev team I enjoyed the game is like action
yes um only note which seems to be shared among other reviews and opinions is that SFX would
be a fantastic addition and I'm sure it's already being worked on it was just not pushed with the
demo not to not to uh also must not forget must not forget to mention the background music is
an absolute banger yeah that'll be a review I like the phase and be a little reference is
plop plop plop get the sprites overall were very cute um okay we compliment also
well maybe shouldn't say also the um the right design was what did you say was rather cute
and it was an enjoyable uh casual gaming experience in the terms of not having to
sweat it's literally uh I need to rephrase that but I want it to be like this is a nice casual
game also the sprite design was rather cute and it was an enjoyable casual gaming experience in
the terms of not having to try hard I can see myself sinking many hours into this game once full
release happens so I can obtain all the unlocks I know for a fact they've got stuff unlocked so
review links we are we're reviewing can you read it or is it too small hold on let me make it bigger
so you can read it easier there you go much easier review I thoroughly enjoyed the claw machine
gacha aspect to this game I would never have expected that a rogue like with a K would be able
to incorporate such a unique mechanic even by a demo standard seeing the weapons unlocks and
characters it is very clear the development team put a lot of love and thought into this game
I can't wait for its release but why is that wrong it is release it's release ah to and to see what
else is inside also the sprite design was rather cute and it was an enjoyable casual gaming experience
in the terms of not having to try hard I can see myself thinking many hours into this game once
full release happens so I can obtain these unlocks only note which seems to be shared among other
reviews opinions is that it's effects would be a fantastic addition I'm sure it's already being
worked on it's just not pushed with the demo also must not forget to mention the background
isn't absolute banger yeah it's like cute by scrawny and the reeflings what no that's cringe the dev
teams don't want to read that the dev teams want to read feedback that's cringy reefling
slam their paint is hard oh we're happy okay I'm gonna put that review on steam let me just
hold I'll put out you I don't know how long it takes for it to appear on scene but I will put
it up later movie theater I drive a Chevrolet alligator I don't I don't know what the thing is
but that was a rather adorable game and I thought that was a very nice casual game I might recommend
the girls that I'm not sure if it's their type oh I'm I'm four minutes early for she be my
my apologies reeflings I didn't realize it was early you know what we still very say scrawny it's
not cringe if you love her oh that's so sweet I love how nice you are today so it's so cute
she's been feeling so loved recently and I'm like so happy for her um what's they called she be
cutting boo
cringe links no you guys don't make me cringe oh my god she's playing titanfall today
oh I hope she loves it I literally I said to she be I was like I'm so excited for your week this
week I'm so excited I really hope she enjoys everything she gets a chance to play um the only
game I've not played a doom eternal I've never played a doom game before but I'm so excited I
really hope she enjoys titanfall don't I don't know if I should DM her and be like there's a section
where you can skip by the way I guess really tedious if you don't know you're allowed to skip it but I
don't I'm not gonna spoil it I'm not I'm not gonna message her that or anything um I have titanfall
too in the roster but I'm so excited like I'm so excited um I really hope she enjoys this you know
a little shitter week a little shitter a little rooty 2d mcshooty week um oh yes I hope there's
funny moments in that I wonder I wonder if she's gonna make the same mistake I did where I thought
I was running up to BT and it wasn't BT at all I was like ah I don't know you leave me alone
um so that titanfall and line has come back a little bit let's go to multiplayer
and we ask you to forgive us for your cringe as we forgive those who cringe against us
if I shake the dev team hands which tentacle should I give them not your front right tentacle
ask your pintosh I think I'm like 99 percent sure a front facing tentacle what tentacle is the
the on a cuttlefish
yeah it's your front two wow you have two what
and you have two
I think your front two arms do the thing
you're front two arms have the ability to ink the rest don't but your first two do
I thought you knew I didn't know you had two winkeys
I mean that's why I've got two holes
one for each one literally no I said it first get wrecked I said it first I said it first
oh my god I didn't know you had two winkeys this whole time
what a strange little thing we are what's up with being cuttlefish honestly
hey we got two for double trouble here's our winky and take it double yeah that's right
that's all I've got that's all I got that's all I got
um
yeah and hopefully I should have an ASMR video up by tomorrow
tomorrow the agendination is actually gas stimulation no gas simulation station what
gas stations simulate are not stimulation stop it stop it it's turning me on
um no the
the front don't we touch everything with your front ones yes I you're allowed to touch everything
with your front one thank you the very lord I don't think I said thank you so just say thank you
thank you for this super chat we're doing gas station simulator tomorrow um and then I kill it
with fire and then a member's ASMR where I'm actually gonna write a script and do ASMR
what a christmas miracle that's all I'm saying an absolute christmas miracle
and can't wait for the gas station it will say I don't want to set the world on fire
I bet she just yaps and says well I'm gonna like purposefully do ASMR and like trigger words
and stuff oh I can't believe it I can't believe the person that does ASMR does ASMR oh it's terrible
did I just flash my fanny I think I did I'm gonna I'm gonna pop myself down a little bit okay
uh I'm uh I'm gonna pop myself who are you
I'm going to do it again and no don't cheer what you've done Mr. Ronnie I just feel bad I feel like
if you're handing money over for like membership ASMR it shouldn't just be me that divulges
I'll do I'll do one serious stream a month how about that
I'm not sure if you did you better do it again for good measure you should be shamed for that
sigma sometimes we get tingles as a treat world on fire cake links oh she has a fat ass call us
cake click don't worry strong it's very easy for you to identify the inking
technical it's the one that's inside you oh that's good that's good I'll give you that I'll give you that
um you know I have to be shamed or the impromptu actually that reminds me the last two membership
streams and swapped because one was a yap and then the other one actually divulged into a script
right and somehow but I passed that script on to the person that I'm collabing with a and another
girl also got it and she was having a blast reading it she was really receptive to which was
really nice and sometimes I feel like I'm bothering people I asked another girl for a collab I can't
freaking stop but she was like oh I just ordered a 3d microphone and I'm like collab with me please
please I'll write the script I'll end it I'll upload it please it's really funny because some
vtubers that have agreed to collab they're like strongy I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I'm not recorded
it yet me who's like so far behind I'm like no no it's fine please delay it more so I have more time
um yeah you didn't ask me for a collab as if one of you own a 3d or in the first place
mommy's suddenly a pleasantly surprised you have two tentacles honestly
I'm be lining for the debut go yeah I want to wrap it up in a year basically um
I don't want to be a year into streaming and I've not achieved muggles the only goal I don't
think I'll achieve is the 100k gamer score unless we did like a marathon very close to the end
did I I didn't tell you my halo achievements popped up like yesterday whilst I was writing my scripts
I don't know what happened but it was like uh welcome uh 5g for the pillar of autumn or whatever
it was called and I'm like why are the achievements popping up now why didn't they pop up I literally
played halo how long ago um so I do have some gamer score I know we played viva pinata and cameo
uh we played skyrim but I didn't finish it but if the achievements are fixed we might jump back
in to get 100 skyrim although I'm a bit resistant to it at the moment because you know when you step
away from a game too long you don't really want to get back into I don't know a controversy
Todd Howard is not gonna like that I'm gonna have to whisper that one
um Microsoft is slow at times I feel that yeah um
he's still can't oh you can't remember where you were and feel like you should start all over
yeah basically it's like oh I don't even know what stage we're at or I think we made it to rifton
because I was talking about the house and rifton and that but yeah Microsoft about as slow as my
you can't even say that
babe um skyrim is easy enough to jump back in yes I can I've 100% in skyrim before and like
under 48 hours that includes the dlc in stores time stores time it's not stores time
it's stores time stores time something like that something like that close enough close enough
honestly call my technical the demo the way you're beating it what does that mean
oh I get it I thought you were talking about demo man from team fortress I was like hmm I'm
trying to put the pieces together how tnt beats you I'm sorry give me a stick goddamn those are my
my hips um you got 13 year old save you jump back in
moment I'm sorry I'm my brain okay I looked up the cult of the lamb gameplay and apparently it's
like bang on 12 hours so I'm gonna purposefully play easy mode so the cult of the lamb stream
might be our endurance but I have a dentist appointment to get my teeth cleaned uh so
it's not on that day I'll need to look at my schedule because I actually don't know what my
schedule is for next week I've already filled that out though um but yeah
as I said I'm gonna rest and then I'll leave that review and then you can publicly see my
my little steam account uh bring the task down for some teeth cleaning ASMR they put like a sweet
substance like on your teeth to protect them once they've finished cleaning them
um and I'm always like hmm banana flavor or something like that I'm like in
teeth things yeah I get my teeth cleaned every six months
oh you don't get the paste it's like flavored paste and they put it on your teeth
and then like they make your rinse and stuff mummies pearly white teeth no no my pearly yellow
teeth unfortunately I was born on the mainland of the united kingdom which means my teeth
unfortunately did not come out the way as intended let them bother me nun
yellow teeth tea drinker real Andrew some people are like really bothered about like
having white teeth in that and I'm just like I don't know I don't even care I don't even care
I think there there's them what is it called uh veneers there's been like a lot of problems
with veneers because people have felt pressure to have like perfect like uniform white blinding
teeth and it's like you know your teeth aren't actually supposed to be neon white right like
you know they have enamel and stuff going on and on right I'm not saying they should be like
fucking orange or anything like that but uh banana tasted like bubblegum your spell
reminds me of the stars not because it shines so bright because your teeth are yellow it's just
the stars we could always do what Americans do and destroy their teeth with sugar and put in fake
veneers oh no apparently the veneer they put it like on top of your shave down tooth uh
I'm a big believer in like keeping your teeth unless you were born unlucky some people spawn in
terribly unlucky terribly terribly unlucky and they you just straight up have like shit dental
genes and like your teeth are just shit they'll just randomly die off and give up and so don't
like that's different but like veneers are so
scary weary you should just get grills you want me to get veal or grills I don't know
they would fit my teeth because I don't have symmetrical teeth can you get grills if you
have asymmetrical teeth or do they need to be symmetrical can you get grills if your teeth
are throwing up gang signs okay that can you get your teeth aren't straight okay how about that
we'll change it if you have crooked front teeth they fit because of the molding oh okay
custom made I think they get fit yeah they're custom made in America though absolutely look
custom depression debuff my teeth that too you can also depression debuff them apparently
grills are very painful I wouldn't bother that oh it doesn't be damn my girl has grails new
donathan no can you do my wait hold on how much how much for grills in Australia I was gonna say
America but I would not put that on my teeth me if I had straight teeth I think vampire ones
would look cool as fuck but I don't have straight teeth so they would just be like shit just like
shit um I know it sounds weird but I kind of like girls with braces no no I get you um
yeah I never got offered braces because there is so my teeth aren't right but they're not like need
braces to be fixed wrong if that makes sense like my teeth just came out a wee bit a wee bit funky
and you got a little a little funky teeth and a grain my teeth some uh it doesn't like improve
teeth feel my teeth I've natural vampire fangs oh that's cute I got one vampire fang and then the
other one I'm grained and down by accident but it's fine it's not that bad feel it to really as
long as the they feel good on my tongue what I'm gonna explore my mouth what
let me check if sheepster is alive
oh no she's not playing time for
is she playing time for I don't see it I think she's just loading up okay I am going to redirect
into none other than Shoebegottenbum I'm going to thank you for um can we get a brace face
oh that's such mean terminology um sheepster is streaming Titanfall too question mark I hope I
don't know uh I don't know if she's having difficulties or not um I will see Giffy Gibbers
tomorrow for gas station simulator if supermarket simulator was anything to go by then I think
we're gonna enjoy gas station simulator I don't know if it's the same dev team I'll look into I
don't think it's the same dev team so it'll be slightly different so no soup no soup
I'm not made my soup yet I need to finish the chicken on the bone
bye bye sir you have a good day take care bye replay I love you I see you goopy goober tomorrow
we do some gas station more like fast money making oh
but I see you tomorrow I give you kisses five kisses because we did five floors okay
and I see you tomorrow okay bye bye have a good day okay and remember to hydrate and stretch
and maybe ink is good for your and have tomato if you can a little tomato a little tomato sauce
enjoy sheepsters okay and if the redirect doesn't work this is the link this is the link oh wait did
I see true gentleman sure no I did I did I went through okay all right I'll see you goopy goopy tomorrow
nap time more like fat time no I'm kidding I'm kidding
enjoy sheepsters and enjoy BT